die Wärmepumpen war im Keller nur oder
ich glaube dass nur ein bisschen spinnst
zuerst müssen wir die Wärmepumpen
loslassen die Leitungen
ein bisschen Gas geben bis Weihnachten
oder müssen wir Vollgas geben und nichts
mit dem Keller und die Wärmepumpe auf
geht's
in der Berufsschule gelernt
aber jetzt pass auf in dem Fall ist es
ja eine Luft Luftwärmepumpe verstehst
und darum werden die Luft wo draußen die
wo er warm ist wer Drehpunkt und da
kannst du mit der warme Luft im Haus
Warzen und wenn die Luft ist sehr
Wärmepumpen du kasperkopf weil wenn die
Luft treu ist dann wird die praktische
so Reibung dass die dann warm ist
verstehst aber die Luft ist doch kalt
wir werden jetzt die warm ja verstehst
einfach nicht jetzt pass auf jetzt
fangen wir ganz von vorne ja eine
Wärmepumpe das ist sowas würde
Kühlschrank
beim Kühlschrank ist ja so wenn du da
die Tür auf machst und dann halt die die
Schweiz den Kühlschrank dann ist er die
Luft
die muss er dann praktisch bei der
Wärmepumpe ist die
heute Luft heute besser Wärmepumpen
müssen